rather than give you a long introduction
to this because we've done a long
introduction enough I just want you to
UM read these with me and think together
about how we might use the tools that
we've got to answer questions like this
so let's just have a look at the first
one it says solve each problem by
writing an equation and then solving it
you may use diagrams to help you think
about the information so here's the
first one there's a picture of Luna Park
there for this exact question it says
four family tickets for a theme park
cost three hundred and fifty two dollars
how much does each ticket cost okay now
some of you might be able to think
carefully on a question like this and
not need to write anything down perhaps
you could actually just do it in your
head or maybe if you reach for a
calculator okay but rapidly we're going
to get into the territory where you
can't just think of a an answer in your
head or you won't know what to punch
into your calculator so I want us to
think about how we can form an equation
that answers this question okay so that
350 Joel two dollars I'm just gonna
write that down and I'm gonna encourage
you to do the same we buy four tickets
for family tickets I should say and they
total two this so I want to write an
equation that gives me that right four
family tickets the cost of that will be
350 s jaws so what could I put on the
left-hand side of the equation Marik
what're you thinking for we can put any
print anywhere we want here X would be
fine a would be fine M would be fine
but I do notice at least in this
question if you look at it again just
look at it again they've asked you to
use a particular pronumeral for this and
sometimes quite frequently they will
what are they get chosen TYT t for
ticket now X is 5 y is fine but if you
can it's nice if you have choice to
choose a letter that's sort of related
to the theme that you're trying to find
right so let's go with the table they've
suggested now hold on a second we've
looked at equations just like this what
should we do to both sides we should
divide by 4 and it's important because
it's actually am i multiply hiding there
so I'm gonna write that divided by 4 and
we should get an answer at the other end
has someone already calculated 88
like that do you happy of that so does
this answer our questions just have a
look back it says how much does each
ticket cost and that is exactly what I'm
after
okay how about like a question to have a
look a question sorry Pat BAE I should
say hello good puppy it's not that very
similar not just the answer is what I'm
after but how would you write the
equation that fits it hmm
here I'll come to your answer in a
second but I will let everyone think for
another moment or so this is puppy okay
what do you have for us here does that
match what you were about to say will
you or different was it gonna be
different but you we like I'm thinking
the same thing we're on the same
wavelength what does this mean there's
twenty lots of a thing they have
suggested we use the letter C the
premium you'll see and it totals to
eighteen dollars so what will I do
should divide by twenty just like I
divided here okay Vishakha did you have
a question or thought that's a lovely
question do I put this point zero zero
do we agree that eighteen dollars with
the dollar sign on the front and $18.00
do we agree they're the same thing I'm
okay with that they they mean the same
thing but it will probably be helpful
here because the next line it doesn't
neatly go in so I'm gonna have some
sense and all that kind of thing so I
might as well can someone help me work
out what should the answer be hmm we got
C equals after we divide by 20 so I'm
going to write it first I'm going to
leave it in the same units I don't want
to change too many things at the same
time so I'm still in dollars right and I
think what I'm getting is zero point
nine right now
I've noticed actually I've been to a
bunch of cafes recently some places
right they're currency like this there
right this thing is zero point nine
dollars or more likely this coffee is
like four point three dollars right
however we generally want to say this
the way that it would be sorry we
generally want to write this the way we
would say it that's
ninety cents we don't do that really for
any other form of your unit now that's
in dollars but you could write it just
as easily with a ninety and I said don't
forget to put that line through it just
to distinguish it from what's happening
over here okay
now just one last quick thing on this
question before I let you loose on a few
other ones right we've said before that
fractions and decimals and percentages
are kind of all equivalent
do you think this which is the same
number would you accept that as an
answer yeah even though it's the same
number I don't like it all that much why
is that what is it about the question
that helps us Leah yeah we know how to
deal with currency right no one writes
their currency like this I mean some
people write it like that people who are
cheap and trying to save ink but no one
writes it like this right so I think we
should write it either of these ways I
think they're both fine okay okay
bhishan your question could you write 90
over a hundred like this is that what
you're asking what do you guys think of
that it's it is the same as 9 over 10
but again I don't think we commonly
communicate currency in this way so I
want to do it in a way that's as clear
as possible I mean technically it's
correct but I think this is much clearer
pencils out of hands I want you to be
undistracted as we feed together so I've
written a pair of equations here
interest I haven't solved them but I've
written a pair of equations in response
to the words in the question what do you
think you have to give me a thumbs-up
thumbs-down are you happy we are they
similar or identical to the equations
you wrote yeah now I'm actually not that
interested in what happens after this
because I think you guys are pretty down
pat on solving equations but it's this
translation stage that I'm really
interested in and becomes quite tricky
it's a skill all of its own ok three
times a number that's what it says a
number is tripled and the result is 99
so you can see there's me tripling the
number and there's me saying what the
result is what is the final answer by
the way 33 right because we can divide
both sides by 3 have a look at the next
one 7 is added to our numbers at the
phrasing I'm just yep sevens added to a
number and the result is 23
so this is my statement but matters with
that right so what should I do the both
sides - 7 subtract 7 and I get n equals
16 fantastic